I've already started with the
eye color example so I figured
no harm in continuing it.
Let's say we live on a planet
or we're a species where
there's only two possible eye
colors: either blue-- and the
genotype or the allele for blue
I'll abbreviate with a
lowercase b --or you could
have brown eyes.
I'm doing it in this salmon
color just because I got tired
of the brown.
We'll do an uppercase B.
And I'll make a few other
simplifying assumptions.
First of all, let's assume that
the expression of this
gene is very simple, that brown
is dominant to blue.
So if you have one of
each, you're going
to see brown eyes.
The only way you're going to see
blue eyes is if you have a
blue allele from each
of your parents.
And the other assumptions I'm
going to make is that this
population essentially has a
stable gene pool with respect
to the eye color gene.
What do I mean by that?
No selection is taking place, no
natural selection based on
this trait.
So, for example, you're not more
or less likely to be able
to reproduce, or the number of
children you have is not going
to be larger or greater
dependent on what your eye
color is in this population.
I'm also going to assume that
there's no mutations.
So for whatever reason, a
chromosome that has a blue
allele can't randomly turn into
a brown or vice versa or
turn into a third color.
I'm also going to assume that
I'm going to have a large
population.
The reason why I'm making all
of these assumptions is
because I essentially want to
have a stable gene pool, at
least relative to this gene.
Relative to the eye color gene,
I want to be stable.
I want to have a stable
allele frequency.
What do I mean by allele
frequency?
I said a large population, but
let's take a very small
population.
Let's say that there's two
people in the population, and
one guy right here, his
genotype is big B and
lowercase B, and let's say that
the other guy has blue
eyes, so he has to be homozygous
recessive.
Let's say this is the
entire population.
Of course, a population of two
can't apply to what I'm about
to do, but I just want explain
allele frequency.
The allele frequency here of the
blue eyes, the blue-eyed
allele frequency
here, is what?
Well, in this population, I
have exactly four alleles.
I only have two individuals,
but they
each have two alleles.
So it's going to be 75%.
75% of the alleles in this
population are blue, right?
There's one, two, three,
four alleles, and
three of them are blue.
The frequency of the brown
allele is 25%.
And this is different than
the actual expression.
If I asked you the frequency
of brown eyes versus blue
eyes-- So this is allele
frequency.
Let me write that down.
That's allele frequency
right there.
If I were ask you phenotype
frequency, if I said how
frequent are blue eyes seen
in my population?
Well, it's only one out of the
two people in my population,
so you'd say it's 50%, and then
for brown eyes, you would
say it's 50%.
So I want to make this
distinction very clear because
it can be very confusing
when people talk
about allele frequency.
Allele frequency is literally
if you were able to go and
look at the actual genotype,
the actual chromosomes of
every person in the population,
and count how many
of them had the blue allele
versus the brown allele, you
would come up with
this number.
This is different than the
actual phenotype frequency.
Now, all of that is just as a
background, because if these
set of assumptions are true and
my population isn't in any
way evolving, then my allele
frequency is going to be
roughly constant.
I have to assume a large
population, because a small
population, just from random
chance, my allele frequency
could start to change.
But let's say my allele
frequency is constant, then
I'm in a Hardy-Weinberg
equilibrium.
All this is a situation
where the allele
frequency isn't changing.
The reason why we're making all
of those assumptions is
because, if we can assume this,
we can start to deduce
some things about what we
observe, what must be the
genotypes in the population or
the frequencies of different
phenotypes and whatever else.
So, for example, if p is the
frequency of blue eyes, so let
me say p is equal to the
frequency of blue eyes, and q
is equal to the frequency of
brown eyes, what's p plus q
going to be?
What's p plus q?
Well, everything is either going
to have blue eyes or
brown eyes.
If this is 20%-- And anyway,
this is the allele.
Let me make that b allele.
Let me make that very clear.
This isn't necessarily
what you observe.
This is the allele itself.
This is the allele frequency, if
you were actually to count
the chromosomes and see what
percentage have the blue
allele and what percentage
have the
uppercase brown allele.
Well, every chromosome has to
have either of those, so these
are going to add up to
100%, or equal to 1.
For example, if 30% of the
alleles are blue, then 70% are
going to have to be brown
because, I already told you at
the beginning of this video,
that we're in a world where
you either have a blue allele
or a brown allele.
Now, what if we don't care about
alleles, we actually
care about the frequency
of the genotypes?
So there's a couple of
things we could do.
We could literally just square
both sides of this and then
think about what
that gives us.
If we square both sides as this
equation, you get what? p
plus q squared is p squared plus
2pq plus q squared, and
you square the other side and
it's equal to 1 as well.
What does this tell us?
What is p squared?
Well, it's the probability
that I get two of the
lowercase blue alleles, right?
What's the probability that I
get two, that I end up with
lowercase b, lowercase
b as my genotype?
Well, I have to get a lowercase
b from my first
parent, and that's with a
probability of p, and then a
lowercase b from my second
parent with a
probability of p.
So it's p times p, so
that's p squared.
What's q squared?
Well, that's the probability
that I get a big B, a
brown-eyed allele from each
parent, because the
probability from parent 1 is q
and then the probability from
parent 2 is also q.
So that's q squared
right there.
Now, what's 2pq?
Well, essentially, this
entire term is the
frequency that I'm a hybrid.
I have a heterozygous
genotype.
And why is that?
Because there's two ways that
I can be a heterozygote.
I could be like this.
I want to do that other blue.
I could get blue eyes from one
parent and brown eyes from the
other or I could get brown eyes
from the first parent and
blue eyes from the second.
I don't know anything about
these parents, so if I'm
making no assumptions, then I
just have to assume that the
probability that I get an allele
from either one of them
is equal to the frequency
in the population.
So there's two ways
of getting these.
The probability of each of these
ways, the probability of
this combination,
is p times q.
The probability of this is q
times p, which is the same
thing, and you add them together
and you get 2pq.
So this is essentially the
frequency of the hybrids in
the population.
I've been kind of
abstract so far.
Let's see if we can apply this
to a real world problem, and
obviously, I'm making some
simplifying assumptions.
Let's say that we go
into a population.
Let's say it's a population of
a million people, reasonably
large, and we observe that
9% have blue eyes.
This is their phenotype.
This is the frequency of the
genotype lowercase b,
lowercase b, right?
I started with this phenotype
blue eyes, but I know, since
blue is a recessive trait, that
they must have two copies
of the recessive allele.
So this is the frequency.
The frequency of having two
lowercase b's is 9%.
Well, if you just look here, I
just showed you that that's
also equal to p squared.
p squared is equal to 9%.
And how do you think
about that?
Well, p is the probability
of getting a blue allele.
It's the frequency of the blue
allele in the population.
In order to get two of them,
you have to multiply p by
itself twice.
So what's the frequency of the
blue allele in the population?
p is equal to the square root
of 0.09, which is 0.3.
So if you went and actually
counted all of the alleles in
the population, you would
actually find that 30% of them
are the lowercase blue.
Now, a much smaller percentage
of people, only 9%, showed the
blue eyes because you
need two of them.
You have a 30% chance of getting
it from your mom and a
30% chance of getting
it from your dad.
So what's the frequency of
a brown-eyed allele?
Well, we know that the frequency
of the blue eyes
plus the brown eyes is 100%,
so that's going to be 70%.
If 30% of all of the chromosomes
or of all of the
alleles in the population are
blue, the other 70% are going
to have to be brown.
So what percentage of my
population are going to be--
Well, there's a couple
of things we can do.
What percentage of my population
are going to have--
Well, I'll do an easy one.
What percentage of my population
are going to have
brown eyes, so if I just look
at the phenotype brown eyes?
I don't even have to
use any of these
formulas for this one.
I already told you 9% have blue
eyes, so the rest must
have brown eyes.
So 91% percent have
brown eyes.
Now, we just said we have 9% who
have blue eyes, 91% have
brown eyes.
What percentage of the
population are going to be
homozygous for brown eyes?
So they need to have the capital
B from both parents.
Well, we know that the frequency
of the capital B
allele is 70%, so what
percent are going to
be homozygous dominant?
Let me draw that.
Homozygous dominant.
Well, the frequency is going
to be q squared.
They're going to have
to get a q.
They're going to have to get
an uppercase B from each
parent, so that's going to be
0.7 squared, which is equal to
0.49, or 49%.
So just starting already from
that one idea, from that one
idea that 9% have blue eyes,
we've already been able deduce
that 91% must have brown eyes.
And of the 91% of the brown eyes
of the whole population,
49%-- this isn't
49% of the 91%.
This is 49% of the population.
49% percent are homozygous
dominant.
And then what percentage
of the population
are going to be hybrids?
Well, hybrids also have brown
eyes, but they're not
homozygous dominant, so
the remainder here.
So what is that?
That's 42%.
42% are going to be hybrids.
And if we go back to
the Hardy-Weinberg
equation, we see that.
So we get p plus q has to be
equal to 100%, or I could just
write equal to 1.
And we figured out
that p was 30%.
That's the frequency of the
blue-eyed allele, the actual
trait, not the observation
of it or the genotype.
And the frequency of the
brown eyes was 70%.
And then this is actually a
breakdown when you square
that, so we also know that
p squared plus 2pq plus q
squared is equal to 1.
This is the percentage of the
population that has blue eyes.
They have two blue alleles,
so that's 9%.
This is the percentage of the
population that has two brown
alleles, homozygous dominant,
so that is 49%.
And then the remainder, this
2pq, this whole term right
here is what's left over.
So 9 plus this 58, this
is going to be 42%.
42% are hybrids.
And if I just talked about
phenotypes, I'd say 9% have
blue eyes and then
the remainder,
91%, have brown eyes.
Hopefully, you found that
reasonably useful.
Just from very simple
deductions, it's almost kind
of silly that this is almost a
separate principle, because
you can kind of deduce this from
very basic ideas, and you
can square both sides of that.
But you can come up with some
fairly fascinating results
about what's going on in a
population because we can
observe maybe the frequency of,
let's say, some disease
that only happens when someone
is homozygous recessive.
So you can go and see, OK,
what percentage of the
population has that disease, but
then doing the math that
we just did in this video, you
can figure out what percentage
of the population have the
allele for the disease.
They're carriers for the
disease, but they don't
actually show it, and
that would be the
hybrids right there.
So this is actually
a pretty powerful
tool you've just learned.